es una actualización en nuestros
esfuerzos para proteger la integridad de
nuestra importantísima elección de 2020
50 en los votos legales ganó con
facilidad si cuentan los votos ilegales
que ellos pueden intentar robar la
elección de nosotros si cuentan los
votos que llegaron tarde estamos
observando los con mucha fortaleza pero
muchos llegaron tarde y yo ya gané
decisivamente muchos estados críticos
incluyendo victorias masivas en florida
iowa indiana ohio para mencionar sólo
algunos
ganamos en estos y muchas otras
victorias por a pesar de la
interferencia electoral por parte de
tecnología los medios como todos lo
saben ganamos por cifras históricas y
las encuestadoras sabían que estaban
equivocadas habían supuestas ridículas y
todo el mundo lo supo en su momento no
hubo ninguna o la supuesta azul creía en
que iba haber una ola azul y eso fue
falso y eso fue hecho fue hecho por
razón en su presión al voto pero en vez
de eso fue una gran ola roja ha sido
reconocido apropiadamente por los medios
creo que estuvieron bastante
impresionados por eso fue después del
hecho de que no se hace nada bien
mantuvimos el senado
a pesar de la situación con demócratas
ellos realmente bueno en estados más
competitivos hicimos un trabajo
fantástico con el senado creo que
estamos muy orgullosos de lo que ha
sucedido ahí tenemos muchos más asientos
para defender gastaron casi 200 millones
de dólares en carreras al senado en el
sur en que toque nada más cientos de
millones de dólares en general en contra
nuestra a nivel nacional nuestros
oponentes los donantes de los oponentes
fueron los banqueros de wall interés sin
gente con intereses negativos bueno en
vez de los ciudadanos y por primera vez
perdimos cero escaños en la cámara su
hablando con kevin mccarthy y él me dijo
que no lo podía creer lo perdimos
ninguna es algo muy inusual pero he
hecho ganamos nuevos escaños creo que
hay muchos más en camino
esto también este también fue el año de
la mujer republicana más mujeres
republicanos fueron elegidos al congreso
que nunca antes es un gran logro
la mayor parte del voto de no blancos en
60 años incluyendo números históricos en
la comunidad latina afro estadounidense
asiática y nativos estadounidenses
es el mayor margen en nuestra historia
vamos a partido creció en 4 millones de
votantes la mayor concurrencia en la
historia de partido republicano los
demócratas son el partido de los grandes
donantes de la gran tecnología de los
medios pareciera que es así y los
republicanos han hecho el partido del
trabajo en estadounidenses eso es lo que
ha sucedido también somos el partido
creo de la inclusión como todos ahora
reconocen las encuestas se cometieron
una interferencia electoral en el
sentido más real de la palabra por
utilizado por intereses poderosos
realmente son unas encuestas falsas
fueron encuestas falsas fueron diseñadas
para mantener los votantes en casa crear
la ilusión de una especie de momentum a
favor del señor bayern y disminuir la
capacidad de los republicanos de reunir
fondos era lo que se llamaba encuestas
su presi va si todo el mundo ya lo sabe
ahora eso nunca había sido utilizado en
el punto al que ha sido usado la última
elección
para resaltar solamente unos ejemplos
del día antes de la elección en
quinnipiac
en toda ocasión bueno había ganado por 5
puntos en la florida y luego habían una
diferencia de 48 puntos y finalmente
gane of florida fácilmente
dejadme
así que me tenían perdiendo a florida
por mucho y terminé ganando florida por
mucho margen más allá de eso fueron muy
precisos
no tenían a él cuatro puntos más arriba
en ohio y se equivocaron por 12 puntos 2
yo también ganó también en el estado ahí
el gran estado cayó muy fácil y el que
tenía 17 puntos en wisconsin y fue
básicamente en parejo
ellos sabían eso no son gente estúpida
ellos lo sabían en su presión ahora hay
unos pocos estados que deben ser
decididos en la carrera presidencial el
aparato electoral de estos estados está
siendo manejado en casi todos casos por
demócratas estuvimos ganando en todos en
todos los lugares clave por mucho margen
y luego milagrosamente estos números se
fueron diluyendo en secreto
y no permitieron una observación legal e
permisiva
fuimos a la corte en un par de
distancias llegamos a poner a los
observadores y complicará y quería que
suben al 60 70 80 pies siempre es afuera
del edificio para observar a la gente el
interior del edificio y ganamos un caso
muy importante hay otros que están
ocurriendo bueno hay mucha litigación
incluso incluso en esos momentos hay una
gran cantidad sobre todo por lo injusta
que la prensa he estado hablando del
voto por correo por mucho tiempo y esto
realmente ha destruido nuestro sistema
es un sistema corrupto y hace que la
gente sea más corrupta incluso aunque no
lo es por naturaleza pero se hacen
corruptos es muy fácil
ellos quieren descubrir cuántos votos
necesitan y luego parecen encontrarlos
esperan y esperan y luego los encuentran
y se ve la noche electoral estuvimos
adelante en las votaciones en carolina
del norte por mucho un número increíble
de votos y todavía estamos adelante por
muchos votos pero no por tantos porque
ellos están encontrando
pero se está encontrando botox en todas
partes es increíble como siga llegando y
como son también unilaterales se supone
que están en la ventaja de los
demócratas en todo caso están tan
inclinados a un lado estuvimos arriba
por cerca de 700 mil votos en
pensilvania gane pensilvania por mucho y
eso resulta diluido creo que ahora dicen
que estamos arriba por 90.000 votos y
siguen llegando y llegando y los
encuentran por todas partes y ellos no
quieren que tengamos ningún observador
aunque ganamos un hard un caso y el juez
quiere que los hagamos ahí ellos están
apelando ellos realmente están apelando
ganamos un caso queremos que la gente
observara queríamos que hubiera
observadores y de hecho están apelando y
esto es interesante me pregunto por qué
quieren apelar si todo lo que tenemos lo
que queremos tener es gente observando a
medida que ellos hacen la tabulación de
los votos así mismo en georgia gun y por
mucho margen mucho del negro
un liderazgo de que se acercaba 300.000
votos en la noche de la elección en
georgia y por cierto esto termino
diluido ahora está bueno llegado un
punto donde pasó de ganar por mucho a
posiblemente incluso está por debajo un
poquito en georgia papers un sitio
bastante lejano completamente no
relacionado con la ubicación de lo que
estaba sucediendo dejaron de contar por
cuatro horas
muchas cosas pasan el aparato electoral
ya está manejado por democracias
también hubo márgenes de 300.000 votos
en michigan estuvimos muy arriba en
michigan ganamos el estado y en
wisconsin fue lo mismo fue
fantásticamente bien y eso terminó
siendo reducido en todo caso terminó
siendo reducido
estamos en camino a ganar a arizona hoy
solamente necesitamos llevar 55 por
ciento desde el voto restante 55 por
ciento ese margen
es un margen que excede mos
significativamente así que ya veremos
qué pasa con esos préstamos en camino a
hacerlo bien en arizona nuestra meta es
defender la integridad de la elección no
permitiremos la corrupción robar un
importe de un aliciente es tan
importante ninguna elección en este
sentido no podemos permitir el silencio
que nadie silenciado votantes
o manufactura de resultados estaba
haciendo cosas públicas por mucho tiempo
pero nunca he visto nada que haya sido
tan inspiración al dar gente llamando
hablando enviando cosas para nosotros
bueno yo nunca había visto tanto amor y
tanto afecto y tanto espíritu como he
visto porque esta gente sabe lo que está
pasando están viendo lo que está pasando
está frente a sus ojos hubo muchas
instancias que serán reportados bastante
pronto hay una gran cantidad de juicios
en estos momentos están intentando robar
una elección están intentando minar una
elección y no permitimos no permitiremos
esto detroit filadelfia saben que son de
los dos sitios más corruptos
políticamente nuestro país fácilmente no
pueden ser responsables por hacer una
ingeniería de un resultado para una
carrera presidencial muy importante en
principal en los demócratas han ido a la
corte suprema estatal para intentar
reventar nuestros observadores
electorales
y con mucha fortaleza pero nosotros
ganamos el caso ellos siguen adelante
ellos no quieren que nadie vaya yo no
quieren quedar de observe a medida que
ellos cuentan los votos puedo imaginar
porque no hay ninguna razón legítima por
la cual ellos no quisieran tener
personas que observen este proceso
porque si fuera correcto deberían estar
orgullosos de esto en vez de intentar
obviamente cometer fraude no hay duda al
respecto en filadelfia los observadores
han sido mantenidos a distancia a una
larga distancia tan lejos que la gente
está utilizando binoculares para
intentar ver y ha habido grandes
problemas
papeles en las ventanas para que nadie
pueda ver la gente que está vetada está
muy infeliz y se está naciendo de alguna
manera violentos
el círculo 11 fallo que georgia para el
día electoral los votos deberían estar
ahí por el día electoral y los votos
siguen llegando después del día de la
elección y había un fallo que decía que
había que tener los votos para el día
electoral en el mejor de mis
conocimientos los votos deberían estar
ahí para el día de la elección pero no
hicieron eso los oficiales demócratas
nunca cayeron que podían ganar esta
elección honestamente yo realmente
querían eso también por eso es que
hicieron lo de los votos por correos
donde hay una tremenda corrupción y
fraude por eso enviaron decenas de
millones de votos no solicitados sin
ningún tipo de verificación o de medidas
por el estilo
le dije a todos que estas cosas
ocurrirían porque ya lo he visto suceder
yo vi muchas elecciones distintas antes
de decidir
bueno arrancar esa increíble elección
con decenas de millones de tarjetones
yendo a muchos sitios a veces y
solicitados esto fue sin precedentes en
la historia de eeuu
ocurrió a pesar de años de quejarse por
la seguridad de la elección ellos se
negaron a incluir cualquier tipo de
requisito para verificar firmas
identidades o incluso determinar si
había elegibilidad de winne elegibilidad
no tenía ni idea simplemente bueno se
escriben las cosas de los trabajadores
hacen muchas cosas malas y hay mucha
información que si llega llegando y
muchos litigios que están ocurriendo y
esto lo está sacando de ustedes ustedes
lo están viendo los vídeos oficiales
vieron la cuenta en principio en otros
estados que la vez que hace parte de una
maquinaria corrupta demócrata por mucho
tiempo ustedes han estado escribiendo
incluso por eso de estar aquí está
demostrando yo fui a la universidad ya
no ha cambiado desde entonces desde hace
mucho tiempo incluso ha empeorado en
pensilvania
los demócratas ha permitido que los
votos sean recibidos tres días después
elección y creemos que muchos más días
después y está contando los sin siquiera
tener marcas postales o ningún tipo de
identificación
entonces no hay marcas postales no hay
identificaciones ha habido una serie de
irregularidades perturbadoras en toda la
nación nuestra campaña se le ha negado
el acceso a observar cualquier tipo de
cuentas en detroit
detroit es otro lugar
y yo no diría que tiene la mejor
reputación por elección para integridad
electoral los encuestadores de michigan
están duplicando los votos pero cuando
los observadores estaban intentaron
manejar esa actividad se les bloqueó la
vista para no poder ver lo que se estaba
haciendo y digamos que ahí se hicieron
un poquitico peligrosos un gran
sitio devotos el litro y también cubrió
las ventanas con largas piezas de cartón
quería proteger y bloquear el área de
cuento no quería que nadie viera los
conteos aunque fueran observadores
legales que se suponía que deben estar
ahí en vitro y tuvo muchas horas de
retrasos bien justificados para esos
conteos el lote final no llegó sino
hasta una hora elevada de la mañana
incluso cuando las zonas serranas de
salud
los botes llegaban y llegaban y no
sabían de dónde venían también se nos ha
llegado negado el acceso observar en
sitios críticos en georgia en múltiples
estados pivotes el conteo fue detenido
por horas y horas durante la noche
electoral con los resultados que se
retuvieron desde ubicaciones demócratas
solamente para ser mostrados después y
ciertamente fueron mostrados y todos
tenían el nombre byd en casi todos creo
que casi todos tenían el nombre by de
ahí como ganador y eso es algo extraño
yo desafío a yo ya cualquier de bocata a
aclarar que solamente quieren votos
legales porque ellos hablan de votos y
creo que deben utilizar la palabra legal
votos legales queremos todos los votos
legales contados yo quiero que todos los
votos legales y acotados queremos
apertura transparencia no queremos zonas
de conteo secreto no votos misteriosos
ni votos ilegales siendo depositados
después del día electoral tuvimos el día
electoral de que son muy fuertes hay un
día de elecciones
no queremos botox después del día
electoral queremos que el proceso sea un
esto esto es muy importante queremos una
elección estas queremos una con un conté
honesto y queremos que haya gente
honesta trabajando ahí porque es un
trabajo muy importante así es como este
país va a ganar así es como los eeuu van
a ganar y nosotros creemos que ganaremos
la elección fácilmente creemos que va a
haber muchos litigios porque hay tanta
evidencia tanta prueba esto va a
terminar posiblemente en la corte más
alta del país pero creemos que habrá
muchos litigios porque no puede haber
una elección robada de esta manera y yo
debo decir estado hablando de esto por
muchos meses ya con todos ustedes he
dicho con mucha energía que los votos
por correo estoy va a terminar siendo un
desastre las elecciones pequeñas fáciles
de manejar y van a ser un desastre esta
es una versión gigante de gran escala y
se está empeorando cada día estamos
escuchando historias horribles
y no podemos permitir que eso suceda a
los eeuu de américa sólo es una duda de
quién gane sea republicano o demócrata
joe y yo no podemos permitir que eso le
pase a nuestro país no podemos tener
tales gracias como están
esperemos que esto sea aclarado espero
que sea pronto muy pronto posiblemente
pasará por un proceso un proceso legal y
como ustedes sabes yo he reclamado
ciertos estados el estado reclamando
estados ambos podemos hacerlos pero yo
tengo una sensación de que los puestos
van a tener que hacer un fallo un fallo
pero ha habido muchos juegos que no
podemos oler en este país muchas gracias
[Aplausos]